President Trump is still asking why his
oldest son is being scorned for seeking
negative information on Hillary Clinton
the president returned to Washington
last night after visiting Paris and his
New Jersey Golf Club a poll released
yesterday shows just 36% of Americans
approve of the president's job
performance in 70 years of polling that
is the lowest approval rating for any
president after six months in office
major Garrett is at the White House
major good morning good morning
president Trump's attorney said Donald
Trump jr. did nothing illegal when he
and two other senior campaign advisers
met with a Russian lawyer and a Russian
American lobbyist in Trump Tower last
June that attorney also stressed that
then candidate Trump knew nothing about
the meeting and most certainly did not
attend President Trump spent the weekend
watching the Women's US Open tournament
at his Golf Club in New Jersey far
removed from Washington where his
administration continues to deal with
the evolving story about his son's
meeting with Russian figures Trump jr.
was forced to admit he met with Kremlin
linked attorney Natalya vessel met skaia
in June 2016 at least two others
attended that meeting that also included
senior White House advisor Jared Kushner
and former campaign Chairman Paul mana
for one was publicist Rob Goldstone who
helped arrange the meeting the other a
Russian American lobbyist Ranaut AK
mention AK mention was born in the
former Soviet Union served in its
military and has suspected ties to
Russian intelligence
I mean opposition research in campaigns
happens all the time president Trump's
lawyer Jay Sekulow insisted Trump Jr's
meeting did not break the law and
offered this confusing new defense
well I've wondered why the Secret
Service if this was notorious why'd the
Secret Service allow these people in the
President had Secret Service protection
at that point that raised a question
with me a spokesman for the Secret
Service pointed out no one was screened
at the meeting because Trump jr. was not
under protection at the time we don't
know what transpired in that meeting
until we get a chance to talk to all of
the individuals who participated the top
Democrat on the Senate Intelligence
Committee Mark Warner took aim at White
House adviser Kushner
amended his security clearance paperwork
to include contacts with Russians it
does seem strange to me that he didn't
forget once not twice with three
separate meetings with senior level of
Russian officials we have another theme
week here at the White House this week
by America an interesting because the
hotel chain and clothing line that bear
the president's name have almost never
done that and as far as theme weeks ago
well they've had a hard time competing
with revelations in the Russia story
Charlie thanks major